rex it is coming et pour l'entreprise ip
software le regard est tourné vers sa
filiale britannique
cette dernière s'occupe de
commercialiser au royaume uni les
produits de la société conçue en france
et la chute de la monnaie britannique
pourrait avoir des conséquences
on verra après dans un en fonction de
l'évolution
tout simplement de la livre si l'on doit
nous augmenter notre tarification pas
mais on sera malheureusement obligés
aussi en tout état de cause de tenir
compte de nos concurrents sur place pour
faire en sorte que notre offre reste
effectivement compétitive cette société
édite des logiciels et propose des
prestations de services informatiques
20% de son chiffre d'affaires provient
du marché britannique
je crois que ce qui est important c'est
qu'effectivement que nos produits
restent dans le coup du marché par par
ce qui se pratique sur ces territoires à
partir de quoi l'instance jeux et jouets
il n'y a aucune raison à ce que demain
matin
votre développement en soit directement
impactés je pense que la relation
établie entre l'angleterre la france ne
se trouvera pas directement impactés je
pense que l'impact va être surtout pour
davantage pour les anglais en termes
effectivement de kout économique que
pour
nos relations commerciales et la
conversation avec son partenaire anglais
se veut rassurante
donc on n'a pas le plan de sortie je
pense qu'au niveau effectivement de la
monnaie bon voilà on ne peut pas plus je
bouge et que savons il ya la certitude
c'est certain le royaume uni a deux ans
pour négocier sa sortie de l'union
européenne pour l'entreprise yvelinoise
et sa filiale anglaise l'activité se
poursuit en restant attentifs aux
indicateurs de l'économie britannique